SOS Médecins sous tension depuis le
début de la semaine les 8 médecins
réalisent jusqu'à 350 consultations par
jour ils font face à une double épidémie
celle du covid et de la grippe mais
également au congé des médecins libéraux
et à la grève de certains d'entre eux
l'objectif de l'équipe aujourd'hui
donner des rendez-vous à chaque patient
entre deux et quatre heures après leur
appel malgré les dizaines de
sollicitations
entre 8h et 10h j'ai réussi à avoir plus
d'une soixantaine de personnes au
téléphone
ce qui fait que voilà c'est toutes les
deux minutes du milieu 30 on a quelqu'un
donc ne pas dire qu'elle SOS ne répond
pas on fait le maximum
on fait le maximum mais c'est vrai qu'il
y a des jours où malheureusement s'il y
a 10 personnes dans la salle d'attente
et qu'on met deux minutes par personne
ça veut dire pendant 20 minutes on va
pas répondre au téléphone et ça c'est
s'il y a que 10 personnes qui viennent
en salle d'attente la salle d'attente
est devenue un véritable all de gare de
nombreux patients se présentent
spontanément c'est le cas de qui vient
de vouloir et Cher où elle ne trouvait
aucun rendez-vous elle s'est donc
tournée vers SOS Médecins j'ai dansé
doctolib mais malheureusement on peut
plus prendre de rendez-vous et j'ai
essayé d'appeler aussi avant de venir
mais c'est le répondeur donc je pense
qu'ils sont saturés d'appel donc dernier
recours je me suis dit on verra bien et
j'ai obtenu un rendez-vous la vague
inédite de rendez-vous provient
également de la recommandation des
urgences du CHU qui demande aux patients
d'appeler le 15 ou de se rendre chez un
généraliste avant d'aller à l'hôpital
autre sujet qui concerne la tous les
médecins le manque de médicaments dans
les officines il s'agit de
l'amoxicilline par exemple que vous qui
n'existe plus actuellement en France
sous forme pédiatrique ça se distille au
compte-goutte ou un posologie adulte et
actuellement je suis en train de faire
des des
dilutions je fais prendre des doses
adultes que je dissous dans un petit peu
d'eau je demande de prendre des je
reconstitue mes dosages de sirop si vous
voulez ça c'est la première fois que je
dois faire ça que je dois composer avec
ça pénurie de médicaments double
épidémie pour l'instant l'équipe de SOS
médecins ne prévoit pas d'accalmie de
l'activité avant plusieurs semaines